so
now let's start talking about these null
models
generative models for graphs that we
that can serve as
uh reference points so the first we are
going to talk about is the erdogani
random graph model basically mention
named
after two famous hungarian
mathematicians
who who developed a lot of mathematical
theory
uh around the random graph generation uh
processes um and random graph model
ernest rainy random graph model
is kind of the simplest way to generate
a graph right uh
we have two variants of it one called
gmp
and the other one called gnm gnp
says it is an undirected graph on n
nodes where
every edge uh appears uh iid with
probability p
so basically for every pair of nodes i
get to flip this biased coin p
and i get to observe whether the edge is
created
and then a different uh version of this
model is called gnm
where it's an undirected graph with n
nodes and m edges picked
uniformly at random um what's the
difference between the two models they
both have the same number of nodes
um they both have the same number of
edges in expectation uh and they both
have edges placed at random between the
nodes so
the point being because in gmp the edge
creations
is stochastic you know in expectation i
will have
n time n times p number of edges
but because of some variance of this
random process i may have a bit less or
i may have a bit more
while in gnm i always have the same
number of edges so now with this simple
generative model let's look at what kind
of networks does this model
produce right so basically the point is
that
these models are stochastic so it means
this random graph models do not you
uniquely determine the graph right the
graph is a
result of a random process so we can
have many different realizations
for the same n and p value so here for
example i show you different
uh random graphs um generated by you
know n equals 10
and p equals 1 over 6.
so what we want to do next is we want to
say okay if i take this
um gmp model and i generate random
graphs from it
you know what would be the degree
distribution what would be clustering
coefficient
what would be the average path length
what would be the connectivity do i get
a giant connected
component and what is beautiful about
gmp
the erdogan random graph model is that
it is that it is kind of so simple that
you can mathematically analyze its
properties right you can
mathematically derive these quantities
um
using algebra alone you don't have to do
simulations and measurements so it's
kind of
the simplest model but it's very leads
to very rich
mathematical literature and very rich
mathematical analysis so there are kind
of
and it's an entire subfield that studies
random graphs
arising from this model so uh first you
know what would be the degree
distribution of the
gmp model the degree distribution of gmp
model would
is a binomial so uh if you def
you say y here is a quick argument you
know let p of k denote a fraction of
nodes with a given degree k
then if you say how many nodes do i um
would i have in a given degree
you say out of n minus one possible
neighbors of a given node
i get to sample or pick k of them so n
minus one choose k is the number of
times i can select k nodes of
out of n minus one and then you know
because i'm saying my d
my node has to have degree k uh it has
to have
k k edges uh be created so the
likelihood of that is p raised to the
power of k
and then the other coin flips have to
result in not edges so that would mean
it's
1 minus n minus 1 minus k
right so that's the probability of
missing the rest of the edges
and if you look at this formula this is
exactly the formula for a binomial
distribution
if you look at binomial distribution it
has this kind of bell
like shape so essentially it's like a
discrete analog of a gaussian
distribution it has
you know average average or mean
of the distribution is simply p times uh
n minus one so average degree
in a gmp network will be uh p
times n minus one and if n is massive
then this is essentially
n times p so this is about
binomial uh about the degree
distribution and again notice
that you know in msn network we didn't
see like this
bell shaped like curve we saw something
very skewed
so clearly uh gmp does not generate
graphs with the degree distribution that
is similar to the
msn network how about clustering
coefficient
right um remember the definition of
clustering coefficient it is twice the
number of edges between the
neighbors of a given node divided by k
times k minus 1 where k is the degree of
that node
and remember also that edges in gmp
appear iid with probability p
so the expected number of edges
between um um this neighbors
e sub i of a given node i is simply
uh the total number of possible edges
times the probability that you know each
one of them
comes comes up uh it actually
materializes
so the expected number of edges so the
expected uh e sub i
is simply k times k minus 1 divided by 2
where k is the degree of node i
times the probability that actually this
this
particular pair of nodes this particular
edge appears
and there is k choose to type a number
of such pairs
as written here so now if you put these
two together
what you get is you get that the
clustering coefficient is uh uh
uh relates to uh to the graph as average
degree divided by the number of nodes
so what does this mean is that the
average what we can conclude is that the
average
clustering coefficient of a random graph
will be small right so basically if we
generate bigger and bigger graphs
and keep the average degree constant
then
the clustering will decrease with the
size of the graph
right and we could even take the values
from
msn network and plug them here right so
average degree was 14
number of nodes was 180 million right so
this means
that our clustering coefficient should
be 10 to the minus 6 right it's
14 divided by 180 million um so
um that's kind of what is the clustering
coefficient
of our erdos-renyi random graph so this
means that
clearly our msn network is not a random
graph
and then the third property i want to
comment on
is connected components and this
is very interesting because in in gmp
you can actually analyze
how is the graph going to be connected
as a function
of the edge probability p right if the p
is zero
then the graph will be empty no there
will be no edges it will be just a set
of isolated nodes
if the p equals one then every pair of
nodes will be connected and that's a
complete graph
what turns out is that the the connected
component
is going to appear when p is um
is of the order one 101 over m which
basically means as soon as the average
degree
gets above one the giant component
will start to appear and if the average
degree is below one
there won't be this large giant
component so we get this kind of
phase transition behavior in gmp
and then of course you can also analyze
what is happening
um as the edge probability is increasing
and for example you can find out if you
know
uh edge probability is of the order 2
times log n divided by n
minus 1 then at that point in time your
graph will be
won't have any isolated nodes it may
still have couple of
disconnected components but every every
node in
will will have some edges so
the point being is that in gmp
the largest connected component occurs
exactly when the average degree is
greater than one and here's a result of
a simulation
where we change the average degree and
here we are asking what is the fraction
of nodes in the largest connected
component and you see how
large is connected component is kind of
small small small but as soon as the
average degree hits value uh one which
means that uh
p is uh greater than one minus one
over n minus one this giant component
starts to emerge and you know what
when the average degree is two it's
already eighty percent of the nodes in
is in the big uh largest component so
the point being uh gmp is connected
as soon as or has a large component as
soon as
uh every degree is greater than one so
uh what have we learned so far we
learned that gmp has a binomial degree
distribution
we learned that clustering coefficient
of gmp
is average degree divided by n we
learned that
large connected component will exist if
average degree
is greater than one so now let's talk
about
uh average path length so the diameter
so to be able to talk about diameter we
need to define this notion of
expansion and the way
expansion is defined mathematically is
to say for a given graph
it will have expansion alpha if for
every subset of
vertices s the number of edges leaving
s is um greater than alpha times
size of the s right uh and here i have
the
this minimum here just to account for
the fact that s
can be more than half of the size of the
graph but if i assume that s
is uh less than half of the nodes of the
graph
so it's the smaller part of the graph
then the
the the point is that if i pick any set
of s nodes
there'll be at least alpha times s edges
sticking
out of that set so equivalently
alpha is the minimum over all possible
subsets of nodes
number of edges leaving that subset
dividing
by the size of the set and the point is
that this is mean this is defined as the
minimum overall
subsets so the way to think of this is
to say here's a set
s here's here are the rest of the nodes
that are not in s
and we are we ask how many edges cross
between
s and the rest of the graph and this
ratio between
edges crossing and the size of s is
called
expansion so uh you know and the way you
think of expansion you can think of it
as a measure of robustness
right uh for example uh what would it
mean it would mean that if you want to
disconnect l nodes
uh from the graph well this means you
need to to cut
alpha times l edges right because if you
say i want to disconnect a set
s from the graph then i need to i need
to cut alpha times
uh size of that set number of edges so
that that
piece that set of nodes is disconnected
from the rest of the graph
um that's another way to think of a
notion of expansion because it tells me
how robust is the network
so let me now give you some examples of
networks with high expansion
low expansion and show you some you know
some something in between
so this would be a network of low
expansion because
i have this one bridge edge right so
basically because
alpha is defined as a minimum over all
uh subsets of nodes
basically if i pick this as a set of s
then
this is the edge that sticks out of the
set so this is
an example of a graph with low expansion
uh this is an example of a graph with
high expansion right kind of everything
connected to everything
um out of every set as there's a lot of
edges
sticking out um and then you know
something that's kind of in between
are these types of networks with
community structure where you have these
subsets with high expansion
and then perhaps the expansion between
the clusters is a bit
lower so um you know so real networks
will be kind of somewhere
in between uh these two extremes
um there is a fact um or one can
mathematically show
that for a graph on n nodes with
expansion alpha
for between all pairs of nodes then it
means that
for any pair of nodes in the graph there
is a path
length the shortest path length of order
log n divided by alpha so basically it
means
the bigger the graph the longer the path
right we have log n
but also the bigger the expansion
bigger alpha the shorter the path length
will be
and now given this fact
what you can then uh what has then also
been shown is that for
uh graphs where um log n is greater than
uh n times p is uh greater than some
constant
the diameter of gmp will be log n
divided by log mp right so basically the
way to think of this
if uh the average degree right
sorry if average degree is greater than
log n uh then the um
then the um diameter
uh will ha diameter of the graph will be
uh order log n
and this means that random graphs have
good expansion
so it takes a logarithmic number of
steps of from
of a breadth first search from a given
node to basically visit all nodes of the
graph right so
basically the diameter is logarithmic in
the number of nodes
and this is interesting because it means
the diameter is exponentially smaller
than the number of nodes right because n
log n
is kind of a is exponentially less log n
x
is exponentially less uh than n so it
means that shortest paths
are in gmp are very short they are only
logarithmic
in the size of the graph so this is the
notion
of expansion and it turns out that
gmp random graphs have high expansion
and that's why
the diameter is order log n again
there is a super cool theory
and ways to prove this uh we can link to
some papers
where you could kind of work out and
learn how to make these proofs
but doing them is kind of outside the
scope of this class
so to give an example here is the um
number of nodes in a in a gmp graph
here um and this is the length of the
average
shortest path and here we keep the
average degree constant so
all these graphs have a different number
of nodes
but average degree in all of them is
constant and you see how basically the
diameter grows
very very slowly as the graph sizes
increases and you see this this
basically is like a logarithmic
shape so now that we have seen what
gmp is and we have kind of worked out
these
properties of it let's compare it to the
msn network
so uh let's compare for example in the
msn network the degree distribution is
heavily skewed right if i plot
a histogram it is just kind of axis
aligned a gmp degree distribution would
has this nice bell shape so clearly the
two don't match
the average shortest path in msn network
is 6.6
in uh in gmp we said the average
shortest path length
will be order log n right log
you know let's say log base 10 of 180
million
is you know six seven eight so it's
close right so we say
yes the msn network has short paths and
uh
gmp also has a short path so that sounds
great
how about clustering coefficient
clustering coefficient of msn network
was point eleven
and we worked out that um
that the um class that clustering of a
gmp graph would be average degree
divided by
n where n is the number of nodes if we
if we enter
the average degree of msn which is 14
and divide by 180 million
we get uh we get average clustering
coefficient to be
10 uh 10 to the minus 8. so clearly
we are nowhere close right we are you
know uh
six uh uh orders of magnitude apart we
are
a million you know we have missed the
mark by a million times
i mean you could you cannot miss more
right it's like as as different as
possible so
clearly totally different and then in
terms of largest connected component
we saw that in msn largest connected
component has 99.9 percent of the nodes
um in in erdos rainy the largest
connected component starts existing when
average degree is greater than one
msn average degree is around 14 so yes
uh you know that that is something that
is matched
so basically what we can conclude is msn
um and gmp uh can
gmp can match msn in terms of shortest
path lens
in terms of connectivity it totally
misses clustering it totally misses
degree distribution so
why why this was interesting because
it's now we know
that msn network is not a random network
it's fundamentally different
from the random graph so let's now
um see if we can extend or fix this gmp
model
to match more of the properties of msn
network
and one sentence i will add here is even
though we you know we work with a single
instance of a network this msn network
it turns out that these properties are
quite shared across
huge class of networks in a sense that
you have skewed degree distribution that
you have short
shortest path lens that you have
clustering coefficients that are quite
high
and that the graphs are connected so
these properties that the msn network
has
are kind of universal across real-world
graphs
okay so to summarize what have we
learned so
far um you know if you ask are real
networks
like random graphs uh the answer is
giant component
yes they it behaves like in a random
graph
every shortest path length also behaves
like in a random graph
clustering coefficient totally different
degree distribution
totally different right so the problem
with the random graph model is the
degree distribution
differs significantly from real network
that um
and also that in real networks giant
component
uh does not emerge through some kind of
phase transition
um and the other biggest problem is that
um
random graphs have no local structure
right like there is no
friend of a friend is my friend type
effect so there is no triangles
the clustering coefficient is way too
low so
the question is are real wor real world
networks
random do they look like gmp the answer
is no
no way however this model is still very
useful because it serves
as a first basic reference point
whenever you want to
generate a graph and compare it to
something
you you would use a gmp model